hello folks welcome to rational science
he only said on the internet that does
physics rationally we don't do it right
we do it rationally and there's a
difference uh write means opinion
whereas rationally we Define so if you
meet the definition rationally uh then
you have a rational Theory
those people who don't like our
definition have a single recourse and
that is to define the word rational
okay uh we're gonna be doing uh number
line today we did number the other day
we're gonna do number line today but
let's begin with our Extinction segment
and here we had uh we were talking about
the alphabet people the other day people
had uh
some questions about that or some
comments so let's start with those here
we have Phil says I didn't think it's uh
I don't think it's genetic meaning you
know whether transsexuals and all this
stuff that we're seeing today well this
got to do with genes right
is which is our argument here uh it's
socially engineered from the top down
uh-huh and so he talks about the current
social engineering uh uh you know the
rich people I guess uh politicians
whoever up there that's running the show
the West is run by hostile Elites okay
and he says something which is of
interest to me at least uh three decades
ago these things didn't exist and that's
not enough time for such a radical
evolutionary change
to occur
and we're going to challenge that okay
let's go with the next fellow and he
says the following he says uh I came
here for physics not for uh LGBT stuff
come on Bill need to guard children from
them
why do we need to guard children from
mama is it contagious or or what or do
you think this is an issue of Education
and if you do well we're going to
challenge that as well okay and then uh
another fellow says related to that he
says all problems we have on Earth come
from Human overpopulation the solution
is not more babies because we're saying
that the
um
expansion of the human race the growth
rate of population growth rate is
slowing down and I guess this follow
says hey that's a good sign you know
we're we're overpopulated as it is and
because we're overpopulated that's why
we're having a lot of these problems
okay well we're going to challenge all
of these uh gentlemen here okay they
have their say and uh we're gonna
challenge that so uh let's go with the
first one and that's that uh you know
the global population
um has increased at a very small rate
over the last thousands of years really
and it was just in the uh 19th century
going into the 20th century that's when
population really exploded we were only
about uh one billion people in 1820 and
that you know you'll get different
values for different uh analysts but
that's uh a more or less good number to
consider you know uh one billion 1820
there's about thereabouts that's for the
whole planet today we're eight times as
many we're eight billion people and we
come pretty much from those uh ancestors
okay and the issue is you know are we
going to continue growing exponentially
the answer is no and then there's only
three possibilities we either go up
continue to expand we go more or less
um uh you know maintain a global
population uh around I don't know eight
or nine billion
or we go to Extinction and guess what uh
we propose here we're saying that we're
going down to Extinction uh and it's got
really little to do with uh with
population in the sense that it's not
that uh the growth of population is
going to slow down and then we're just
gonna Whittle down to zero no no uh it's
going to be an exponential drop we're
all gonna die almost simultaneously okay
so it's not a gradual decline that's
what we're gonna argue here if it were a
background Extinction it would we say
that humans will die in a mass
extinction we die all of a sudden okay
so and there's nothing we can do about
it and it's guaranteed it's not that uh
say well maybe no no it's guaranteed
okay that's what we're we propose here
okay uh I'm just gonna show a fellow who
talked about genetic diversity we say
that we have lost our genetic diversity
over the
um
over the centuries
and a lot of people have problems with
that they think that
um any species whether plant or animal
gains genetic diversity because we have
new mutations every day
that's their notion that's what I guess
that's the worldly wisdom
and we're saying that's absolutely not
true at least that's not what we vouch
for here we say something different we
say that
we can only lose a species can only lose
genetic diversity it has no way of
gaining genetic diversity by that I mean
the whole pool okay I don't mean just
one or two individuals I'm saying the
whole population as a whole it can only
lose genetic diversity and I have a
graph that's uh in one of my books okay
and it looks more or less like that you
can see that the species can only lose
genetic diversity especially when it
becomes sedentary and no longer migrates
and we are not migrating people anymore
that age has long gone okay it's a
steady decline and it's got to do with a
couple
factors one of them is the um
founders effect and the other one is uh
population bottlenecks okay so I'm not
going to go into detail there but all we
say here is that we can only lose
genetic diversity okay and uh because of
that uh yeah the spell says well can
that happen in 30 years that we that are
that because of our loss of genetic
diversity there are such major changes
that we see all around us
okay and I think there's two factors
there and one is that we have more
information today and a lot of people
have come out of the closet so those are
two factors that influence that but I
just want to address essentially these
three fellows uh with Calhoun's
experiments okay and that's uh John
Calhoun ran experiments from what is it
1948 to 1975
uh number 25 uh Universe uh what is it
utopian Universe number 25 was his uh I
guess Masterpiece you could say his main
uh experiment he put four mice I'm sorry
four pairs of mice uh male and females
normal mice you would say but remember
it took him out of the stock existing
stocks it's not like he went out hunting
you know in the wild for mice now he
just said give me four pairs of mice and
they gave him four pairs of mice that's
what he started out with and there we
have our perfect problem because those
mice were already
um you know we'd have to look at their
genetics and I don't think he did that
he was a psychologist he was studying
um Behavior okay and the main thing I
got out of his experiments he's the
first guy
I've seen a couple other experiments but
I will I will concede to him being the
first guy to produce homosexuality in
the lab
okay he produced it with animals he did
not produce it with uh the people who
are on top of us who um
impose governments on us none of that
you know Elites and so on it's got
nothing at all to do with that okay it's
got to do with genetics with Biology
okay and it's got to do with two things
first the fact that uh they started out
with this founders effect uh four pairs
of mice okay they were normal in general
you know uh male one got a female and
made his nest and the other guys did the
same thing so you have four houses
essentially that's the starting point
and from there they ended up with 2 200
mice after several Generations
and at towards the end of that process
and he did this uh again he did this
experiment many times
um at least 25 times and he ended up
with homosexuals and Altis okay the mice
as he said has had stopped being mice
okay and this is what his experiment
looks like okay he had uh this
um I guess it was like nine square feet
uh space and then he just allowed the
mice to do anything they wanted they had
all the food they wanted yeah they had
all the water they wanted they had no
Predators they had no diseases and they
just multiplied you know at first it was
Heaven it was uh you know they were in
Paradise but as the population grew and
you had density dependence uh birth
rates and so on uh that's when the mice
started acting kind of weird and he
suggested John Calhoun suggested that
this is a uh what is happening to the
human race okay there's the whole
apparatus okay he had them in there
okay so this is how he started and
um uh yeah let me remove this
okay so that's that was his experiment
and again it had nothing to do with
rulers uh imposing things on the uh
please below none of that okay and uh
this is how the experiment when it ended
all of them ended up in extinction he
did it with mice he did it with rats
also they all ended up in extinction
they all had the same curve where you
have an exponential growth at first then
the curve uh you know starts getting
asymptotic and then finally ends up in
extinction they stop having children the
females become aggressive okay uh they
don't mate
uh sounds like the day like humans today
so uh you gotta look at John Calhoun's
experiment you might change your mind a
lot about a lot of stuff out there okay
all I can say is
um what we're seeing today uh I think
has to do with Biology and not with
politics I don't think it's a question
of nurture it's a question of nature
it's got to do again with uh population
bottlenecks in this case they did not
have that except one when he crashed and
finally went down but it does have to do
with founders effect remember the
grandfathers of these were the four
couples okay they were around for a
while and eventually you know they uh
created this whole population so they
all come from the same genes and uh they
didn't have the the factor of you know
the uh bottleneck Factor but uh they did
have the density pendant factor and
that's another issue you should research
if you're interested in the subject
anyways changing a little bit the
subject how we say that humans will die
not because of this because of
um population bottlenecks or genetic
diversity problems no it's going to be
the economy that's going to be die in a
mass extinction mass extinction is
related to the collapse of the global
economy that's what we propose here okay
and here's a bit of news that came out
the other day China's record
unemployment has some young people
seeking simpler life and it talks about
the some of the problems that the youth
in uh China have and uh what it is is a
lot of them went to school to college
and so on but there are not enough jobs
for them in other words for the new
generations and it says you had a huge
expansion of University education in
China over the last couple of decades
creating a surplus of Youth competing
for limited White Collar jobs meanwhile
a lot of jobs at the economy is he
creating are blue collar jobs okay so in
their in their situation they have
um
uh well
services uh the economy uh converted
into a service economy the Chinese
economy for the first time more than 50
percent of GDP came from
um Services instead of manufacturing
that was about a few years ago it was uh
around 2014 2015 thereabouts and today
there's more services than uh as far as
GDP is concerned right as a percentage
of GDP and as a percentage of Labor uh
there's more services than manufacturing
and that number is just going to
continue increasing on the service side
and decreasing on the manufacturing side
it's happened to all economies in the
world it is happening to all economies
on the planet not a single one is an
exception okay all of humanity is
becoming service oriented
and stop being manufacturing what's the
problem with that well like I like to
say you're standing next to God there
you know in heaven you're looking down
on the planet okay from space What Do
You See
well you see what is constructed what
humans have constructed you see the
tangible stuff you see houses you see
highways you see boats cars planes You
See Fields of corn that's what you see
from up there you do not see the
contracts you do not see the banking
transactions you do not see the um the
uh what is it the interest rates
uh none of that uh none of that
Contracting Etc none of that that
belongs to Services is what you see the
promises they're not there and most of
the work today is going into that region
into the region where it's invisible
there is
services are intangible
okay so we're putting people into the
intangible world and taking them out of
the tangible World specifically from
Agriculture and you know agriculture in
the in the advanced Nations has already
almost practically disappeared you only
have one to two percent in most advanced
Nations uh with agriculture about 14 15
maybe even up to 20 percent is
manufacturing and 80 percent is
services and every country in the world
is moving in that direction we're moving
in I call services unemployment
so if you're in the service industry you
say hey I got a job yeah you're not
producing anything all you're doing is
exchanging money around and that money
ultimately comes down to buying uh the
food that you need to live one more day
okay so it's the agriculture that's come
down we're so efficient at it that you
know we don't need agriculture we don't
even pay attention to it because we say
Hey you know I want something I'll just
go to the corner store and get it you
know potato or whatever you want you
know not even that because people go to
fast food restaurants and it's already
manufactured packaged and the whole
works for you right all you have to do
is have money how did you get that money
someone gave it to you and so we're
passing money around in the service
industry eventually to buy uh stuff that
keeps Us Alive one more day which is
known as food okay so when the global
economy collapses you know in the days
of the um
um
everybody got their own food you were in
direct contact with food okay Hunter
gathers you know in those days they
caught their own stuff uh since then you
know we've gotten away from the only
thing that keeps Us Alive which is food
and today we go through it in a
intermediaries you know uh middlemen and
they get the food for us we don't even
know how they produce it we don't know
where it comes from how it's transported
and none of that we know nothing of that
all we know is we go to the store and
magically it appears on the shelves
that's how efficient we are and its
efficiency that's going to kill us
okay uh just to show you here's another
country he just had an election that's
turkey and they voted for Mr erdogan
again United States is not very happy
about that anyways uh there there's this
they voted for him despite they say this
article is here says despite that turkey
is undergoing some economic problems
okay and says critics blamed you a
crisis on erdogan's policy of keeping
interest rates low okay economy is uh
generally recommend raising rates to
combat inflation because one of the
problems is inflation they have
skyrocketing rants okay and they have
problem buying basic Goods okay uh
sounds like a common story that we see
every in every country in the world okay
and says uh again uh inflation the fact
that uh they say um public spending is
unsustainable minimum wage problems
pension increases etc etc etc all the
problems that every country in the world
today has there is no exception to this
you pick the country you want to pick
Peru you want to pick some
Uganda you pick the country and you'll
see that it's got the same problems
we all have the same problems okay and
the question is whether that's going to
continue or whether the global economy
is going to crash when it crashes what
do we mean by crash means that money
will be no more nobody will accept money
nobody accepts money we're all dead
because we need money to buy food and
nobody will work for money nobody will
accept money and nobody who produces
food will accept money so why will they
produce or distribute you know transport
the food to you if you've got nothing to
give them except some paper or some
number on the internet okay that's it
and so here's the trend uh that you we
can see in the last maybe hundred
thousand two hundred thousand years uh
we were hunter-gatherers for most of
those times those years uh maybe 10 15
up to 20 000 years ago maybe we did
started doing farming some kind of
farming it's known as the Neolithic and
uh and then we went into manufacturing
about 300 years ago you know 200 300
years ago industrialization some
countries not all countries in the world
and today we're in the service world and
we've pushed the other sectors we're
squashing them we're muscling them aside
okay what is uh Services unemployment
and that's on top of the uh formal
unemployment that we have so uh the
question is what's the next uh category
if we've already done Manufacturing
Services where's where's the next
category going to come from what is the
next category and to make things worse
within the service economy we've moved
into Services uh into
um internet services
before we used to have some Hands-On
services like you know barbering or
Landscaping those require hands their
services you know scratching your back
that requires a service that involves uh
touch right handling or whatever today
the services are moving more going in an
abstract direction today services are
internet services and there's nothing
tangible there for sure
so that's the trend okay how are we
going to die well here's an article that
tells you what happened in the past we
disagree a little bit with it in fact
quite a bit and here it is says South
African fossil review ancient BEAST's
epic journey to Oblivion talks about the
Permian and the fact that you had these
mammal-like reptiles at the end of the
show at the end of the Permian that died
why because they say volcanism happened
and uh that's unlike what happened in
the Cretaceous where an asteroid
allegedly hit the earth and killed the
dinosaurs okay so we have these
catastrophes uh comets and volcanism and
there's a couple more here's uh here's a
a general idea of what these people
propose they say there's climate change
there's gamma rays you know these are
these are the proposals today the most
important ones okay and the question is
whether any of these had anything
whatsoever to do with
um with the extinction of of these
animals and here we say none of them had
anything whatsoever to do with the
extension of the animals okay so here's
um here's the uh Permian more or less
this is what they suggest uh there were
explosion especially from the uh
volcanoes in India okay and they cover
the land essentially that's what they're
saying and so when they when uh this
expressed throughout the world it also
affected a little bit the climate Okay
and so all these factors together killed
the animals that's that's what they say
and the problem that all these theories
have is selectivity they cannot explain
how one species died and another one
survived and that's the only issue they
don't address or sometimes they make it
even worse they have an uh ad hoc uh
mechanism for each species or for each
family or for each plant because we're
not only talking about animals here okay
and so these were the
couple of the animals you know the uh
that lived towards the end of the
cretacea of the Permian and they are
mammal-like reptiles you can see they
look more or less like a lion and
something similar to that the difference
is that these animals laid eggs
so they were not mammals they were
mammal light they were tigers that laid
eggs okay think of it that way so they
uh they were mammal reptiles so to speak
they had features of both uh some little
animal maybe uh in the wings
[Music]
um
was
um the one that gave birth to humans
eventually okay because I'm sure that we
can trace our lineage all the way to the
Cambrian and before pre-cambia okay some
animal gave us births some lineage that
was there in the wings some tiny animal
probably and eventually exploded and
gave birth to the mammals and from
mammals became us
and others believe that it was God's
magic wand so we have these versions
Cretaceous uh this is the main one and
you can see it's a I think it's a bunch
of baloney an asteroid hits the Earth
you have all this uh Brimstone falling
on the earth creating all these uh fire
tsunamis burn the animals I guess you
know and the whole planet was covered in
fires we had a the Earth was a cinder
okay that's the
the official version okay and again the
question is if that happened how do you
explain cell activity how do you explain
that some plants survived basically the
angiosperms right the ones that really
stayed behind were the conifers the
gymnosperms so you got to explain that
cell activity that's what you got to
explain otherwise you don't have a
theory of Extinction and not not a
single paleontologist on Earth has it
okay and so here we have uh this is what
they portray you know that you have all
this fire coming down and stones from
the explosion they fall on the poor
dinosaurs and there you see the comet
hitting the Earth that was it you know
or the asteroid right
and so this is it this is what they
propose
and the issue is uh they say it fell in
the ocean fell in the waters really in
the Gulf of Mexico okay
and uh so another version or a parallel
version because they need to find out
how to kill all the animals right and
here's uh here's this version which is
that it created these tsunamis that
flooded the land and just drowned
everything out
so we have the fire version and the
water version fire water right okay so
the water covered the land I guess this
is like the biblical
um 49s and 40 days of uh you know uh
Noah's Ark more or less that's that's
the version
so they can't make up their mind whether
the animal plants and animals were
killed by uh fire or by water and then
you have the animals underneath the sea
you know especially the reptiles you
know here you have the Moses are okay
this is what he looked like they show
him killing
um a shark there but really the
mosasaurs they're apparently from what
the studies show uh they were primarily
Hunters of ammonites they loved
ammonites it turns out that
um the ammonites uh eight uh certain
types of Plankton looked like this for a
minifera with the forums okay and you
can see the ones from the Cretaceous
compared to what followed which were
much smaller the ones from our days uh
were much smaller than the ones from the
Cretaceous so the uh ammonites uh ate
these Cretaceous forums and uh the
mosasaurs ate the uh
ammonites so that was the chain it turns
out all three disappear
now that's funny how did they how did
the asteroid that do that underneath the
sea that's what you can answer
okay so uh what do we propose here what
we say the same thing doesn't happen to
the dinosaurs and the same thing
happened to the Permian mammal like
reptiles or synapsids will happen to us
and we cannot Escape that same process
here's the process I'm going to show it
for the terrestrial uh days of the
Cretaceous uh not going to talk about
water or air okay just uh you know not
uh air and sea but just uh land and here
it is it's known as the Cretaceous
terrestrial Revolution what happened was
from uh almost uh the first third maybe
even half of the Cretaceous you had the
angiosperms they expanded throughout the
land and muscled aside all the conifers
which is what the dinosaurs ate
specifically the
um uh cycad like the
cicadioids uh plants like the William
sonias and so on so they muscle design
the angiosperms muscle aside the
gymnosperms which is what the animals
ate the the ruling animals the dinosaurs
ate and eventually the forest dried up
uh they didn't Disappear Completely not
all gymnosperms disappeared but it took
out so much from the dinosaurs that they
had trouble finding food and so they
died in a mass extinction which is the
lack of food the ecological pyramid is
what overturns
okay and here's uh what I'm talking
about here is a graph four you can see
it okay the demographic uh
pyramid of the plants overturns over
time because again they've been around
for too long their genetic dis diversity
disappears they've uh
changed so much over the years that they
can't change no more okay there's not
Mother Nature doesn't have any more
capacity to make them change anymore and
so they reach a point where they you
know they can't expand they can't
uh occupy new niches okay
uh and meanwhile you have the new plans
which in this case were the angiosperms
which are muscling them aside which are
more vibrant which are more advanced
plants and that's what the new
generation of animals that's going to
take over the mammals uh are going to be
eating they grow with they expand they
radiate with the new types of plants
with the angiosperms and the dinosaurs
were stuck with the Conifer specifically
the cicadioids and uh cycad like plants
and those are the ones that disappear
okay and yeah when they disappear turns
out yeah the dinosaurs disappear no
comment necessary it's just a regular
Evolution okay and yeah what you have
for the animals okay is the overturning
of the uh ecological pyramid which you
see at the bottom there and it's the
many chasing the few the plants world
dies under their feet and so they're
competing forever fewer uh resources and
that's essentially what's going to
happen to humans and there's no way we
can do anything about that why because
um if money is no more and again that
long story to explain why we end up with
no money or nobody wanting money anymore
um if money has no more no one has an
incentive to produce or distribute food
and we're all dependent today you know
on someone doing that for us uh 90 of
humanity maybe or some countries more
some countries less but a lot of people
in the world uh depend on you know
nobody grows his own food especially in
an apartment in the city we all depend
on someone else to bring the food to us
and that's the only thing that keeps us
alive
and if money disappears how are you
going to get food well I'll tell you how
you're going to grab a gun go out into
the country or to your neighbor and
you're going to take that food away from
them that's the way it's going to happen
so there's going to be murder
cannibalism the whole works and that
happened I think at the end of the
Cretaceous as well when you had some of
these T-Rexes some of these big animals
and they started killing each other as
well you know I mean when you're hungry
you eat your own kind
so uh get ready for it okay that's what
our future looks like and it's probably
going to happen quite soon I think uh
within my days maybe uh certainly anyone
who's 20 years old 30 years old I think
they're going to see the end of the
world
okay let's move on to uh the number uh
World okay and we talked about numbers
the other day
and it turns out that the um
mathematical establishment they don't
know what a number is they haven't been
able to define the word number they
don't know what a number is here you
have two examples I covered them the
other day real quick here like uh
Merriam-Webster says number a word
symbol letter or combination of symbols
representing what a number absolutely
love that definition what is the number
uh uh thing that represents a number
okay now you know and yeah they confuse
number with numeral numeral is what is
the definition of that the symbol that
you use to replace or to represent a
number okay numeral is not number two
different things okay and then you have
um the Wikipedia says a number is a what
mathematical object
mathematical object yeah what is it used
for to count or to measure
I I really don't know what we're
referring to is that like a hammer you
know what do they use to measure you
know or count or hammer
so yeah we don't know what a
mathematical object is we covered that
the other day so you can look that up
okay
so uh yeah we have no idea what a number
is because it's not properly defined
okay and when we look at mathematical
object I went over that the other day
you just get more more and more run
around that's all you get okay
okay so here we synthesize and say what
is a number well according to the
establishment it's a noun
okay and a equate it with a numeral with
a mathematical object you know those are
all nouns and we're saying no uh numbers
a verb
it's a county it's a verb to count
that's what number means okay uh you can
count to Infinity that's where the word
infinite came from okay that means you
can count forever you never stop
nobody's ever done that nobody's gone to
infinity and back you know unless you
went to heaven God maybe has counted to
Infinity I don't know
um and so under the universal movie we
consider it a dynamic concept so we put
it at the bottom and here it is number
is at the bottom not at the top what are
we talking about here well we're saying
that at the top you have the static
Concepts okay like object distance
location existence no motion involved
you can synthesize that in a single
frame of the universal movie for the uh
Dynamic Concepts the ones at the bottom
you need at least two frames of the
movie okay what is a this means that you
need at least two locations okay motion
is two locations or more and a number is
counting so obviously that's a verb and
therefore it requires at least two
frames of the universal movie
so number is a dynamic concept now a lot
of people or a couple people had uh
problems with that uh with defining uh
number as counting and finding it as a
dynamic concept here's one of them he
says the following says a number is a
word and a symbol representing a count
an arithmetic uh value used for
representing it representing the
quantity okay and again uh when you talk
about representing a count you're
confusing number with numeral okay a
numeral is that
okay so that's the issue number is the
other words that you had there count
quantity amount value you know that's
that's what number is number is counting
okay you're you're just uh putting a
symbol like uh the number five okay
that's the numeral and that's just the
symbol and you're representing what
you're representing Counting
and uh so you know it's uh it's count
and quantity which is number the
representation is numeral okay
yeah okay let's remove this one here and
we'll go with the next one fellow says
same fella I think says one of the most
important numbers is the number Pi found
all through nature and Pi is three uh
Point fourteen okay it's just a relation
between circumference and diameter but
what's the problem there you can't count
to 314. you can only count to
whole numbers in other words to integers
you can go three four five six you can't
go three and a quarter three and five
fifths or whatever or four-fifths or
whatever uh you cannot count uh to
fractions to decimals okay you can only
count you know whole numbers integers
and you can't count to zero so again
Counting is what number is and you can't
count to 314 you can't count two
fractions or decimals which is simply a
different form of a representing a
fraction
okay so uh file says
um
measuring is counting number of cons of
consistent length segments absolutely
not okay you can't count half a segment
okay you can only if if you're going to
count you're going to count segments and
uh that eliminates any fraction or
decimal okay so no you can't count to
less than one
increments of less than one
okay so here we have another phone he
says the following he says uh
technically things like 10 24 wouldn't
be a number then
uh-huh why he says having those symbols
next to each other is like period in
decimals and uh Slash infraction in
other words he's saying you have these
symbols one zero two and four one next
to each other right and they represent
different things he says he says each
spot represents operations of future
Counting
okay and so he specifies there he says
in 1024 the first tells you how many
thousands to count the second how many
hundreds and so forth okay tens and
units however each time thousand or a
hundred is another operation to be done
and again he doesn't understand what
we're saying here uh numeral represents
uh
number and number is to count so the
numeral is a symbol that we use to
represent to count okay
um 1024 is a single numeral the whole
thing
okay you don't chop it up and say oh the
ones over here represents thousands we
don't care about that okay there's a
single numeral there okay and here I'll
give you an example here you have the
same number in Roman numerals okay and
for those of you who understand neuroman
numerals there you have the M the double
X's C uh IV Etc uh and those are Roman
numerals uh you can say well the M
represents thousand but see you have two
two x's there and each X represents ten
and if I wanted to represent 30 I would
put three x's and so now it's not
positioned properly as it is in today's
nomenclature but I do an even better
deal than that there's the E with an uh
cursive E right with an uh accent mark
and that's my version of a thousand
twenty four
okay so that's my 10 24. there's no
positions no no calculation no
operations to be done there and there's
the Klingons version a squiggly line
there okay that's his version of
1024. okay so again you're confusing the
issue here you're thinking it's an
operation and that you gotta count no no
you don't have to do anything what we're
saying is we're defining the word number
and we're saying number is simply to
count you count it up to there whether
you did or not that's what the symbol
represents it represents a number that
you counted to okay it's a value an
amount I don't know if I I don't think
there's a single human being ever that
ever counted to a million
okay listen to that again not a single
human being has ever counted to a
million taking the troubled account one
two three four five a thousand a
thousand one a thousand two a hundred
thousand one hundred thousand two no one
has ever done that I'm almost sure you
know unless he he took a bet hey I'm
going to count to a million you know why
would anyone do that
so so when we see a million
did you count to a million no that's
just the symbol that represents one with
six zeros represents
the the value the accounting up to a
million that's all it means so we're
talking about the meaning of it so 1024
represents counting it doesn't mean that
you have to do or I have to do some kind
of operation where I have to count to a
thousand to a hundred and I'm gonna put
the thousands here in the hundreds here
no no forget about all that
it's a single value a single numeral
called 1024 we use four uh symbols there
to make one numeral irrelevant okay like
I'm saying you know the Klingon only
uses a single squiggly symbol there and
he represents 1024 with that squiggly
symbol okay so no operation needed what
we're talking about is the definition of
number what does the word number mean it
means it's a verb to count okay so let's
get that right
um
and so the fellow continues he says I
think it's the same fellow he says uh is
it that you can can or you have counted
them what about counting 10 to the 10 to
the 10 to the 10 you know can't do it is
it not a number then
uh yeah again uh it's uh we're talking
about the definition in this individual
did not understand that we're talking
about the definition of number what does
the word number represent what what do
we mean when we say number and it's the
verb to count it and here's a
illustration of that I showed that the
other day let's show it one more time
this is Count okay it's how many times
you move your finger
okay so we say uh numbers to count and
what are numbers many numbers uh naming
each Shake of the hand so you say this
is one this is two because it follows
the other one this is three this is four
this is fine we represent those symbols
we have a name for them we say this is
five this is six those are the words we
use okay what are we doing we're
counting that's what we're doing does it
mean you have to count no we don't do
that anymore we don't have to do that we
can say a million without counting to a
million and we use a symbol that is a
one with six zeros to represent it okay
that's a story okay now uh that leads us
to what a number line is because just
now I showed you that
um
you had many numbers there you know you
one two three when you have more than
one well now you have a number line okay
and people say what is a number line
look like what is it and here's Bill
Gates
number line okay you can take one this
one to the bank okay this is Bill Gates
number line here it is take a snapshot
of it it's gonna come and go
okay there's there's ability's number
line
and a lot of people don't like it they
say Bill I don't like your number line
uh because it's kind of messy
oh you know you go from one to two then
from the two to the three three to the
fourth fourth of the five to the six uh
around the corner to the of the eight to
the seven then to the eight then down to
the nine
it's a number line it's not a very
straight line but that's my number line
going from one to nine okay yeah people
don't like that and say Bill you know I
think I can do better okay and what do
they do well they have this instead
they say those are the number line see
how neat it is uh everything is spaced
out properly uh we have number one
underneath each one Etc this is the
official the the super duper number line
okay that's a number line okay and yeah
we have a problem here because this is
quite misleading
is misleading because
it's straight it looks like a line you
know the typical line and what's not
shown here is that it also has Direction
okay and all that is misleading okay
that's where the problem starts when you
think that that is a number line and
you've represent it with this line with
a little sticks a little arrow at the
end you know you say that's a number
line now it is yeah it's a number line
in a sense but uh it's very misleading
and I'm going to go over what is
misleading about it okay
here's a look up a definition and this
site official site instead of defining a
number line says it helps students
visualize number sequences and
illustrate strategies for counting uh
comparing adding subtracting Etc right
choose number lines labeled with whole
numbers fraction decimals so they
include everything in there negative
numbers or use custom number line with
or without tick marks and set your own
interval so they have all these
variations where some of them don't have
tick marks some of them don't have the
proper interval some might
um
have um you know exponential
tick marks and so on they're not the
same as the
typical
day
Cartesian coordinates right so you have
all kinds of variations on the number
line
uh we have a problem with what these
people are proposing and let me tell you
why here it is uh here's the number line
official version and you'll find it in
the Wikipedia and I'm saying official
because anywhere else you'll find more
or less the same definition number line
in elementary mathematics and really
arithmetic right a number line is a
picture of a graduated straight line
that serves as visual representation of
what the real numbers every point of a
number line is assumed to correspond to
a what real number and every real number
to a point and it talks about it
continuing forever in each direction and
you can see the arrow there for
direction and those uh numbers integers
in this case uh they call them points
okay and
um and you see also negative numbers
okay you have also the zero in there and
the question whether all of that and if
any of that makes sense
um here's a first uh what the real
number is okay here's a real number
definition says real numbers include
rational numbers like positive and
negative integers fractions and
irrational numbers in other words any
number that we can think of except
complex numbers is a real number for
example three zero one point five three
and a half three halves a square root of
five and so on okay those are all real
numbers so they include everything in
the number line number line includes all
real numbers the problem here the first
problem is that uh math has no use for
objects such as point and line they're
object-wide because they have shape in
this case they're two dimensional
essentially that's what they're
illustrating you know you could think of
it as a 3D Point 3D line no problem but
they're at least 2D okay and the point
you know it doesn't belong to math at
all what are you going to do add points
subtract lines what are we going to do
this nonsense okay so the point and the
line does not belong neither one belongs
to number line yeah to mathematics and
then the other problems again uh is
Direction and we're going to have
another problem with a number line which
is orthogonality which is you know
perpendicularity
and so here we have
um the problem is that they uh take time
you know the word time and first of all
nobody's ever defined the word time okay
that's the first problem but then
they're going to say that uh they're
going to illustrate it as a number line
and call it a dimension
okay so this is where the problem is
time in physics is operationally defined
as what a clock reads that's out of the
Wikipedia okay you know there you have a
perfect scientific definition what a
clock reads okay whatever that is okay
minutes seconds I don't know what it
reads I thought I read the clock not the
clock reads anything okay and says the
operational definition of time does not
address what the fundamental nature of
time is great we don't know what time is
but they say it's what a clock reads
they have these contradictions they
chase their tails around but there we
have an example and what you see at the
bottom is time okay it's going towards
the right you see that it's a number
line because it's got all these numbers
in between it's got the partitions you
know little tick marks so they
illustrate it as a number line okay so
you can see that
I think there's no doubt there and here
you have another version of that uh
that's known as space time diagram and
again they Illustrated this time upwards
okay and they illustrate time as a
number line okay so they call this uh or
they illustrator is a number line and
you see that it's got a couple problems
the one is it's orthogonal it's
perpendicular to space to the space
number line because that's also number
nine and it's uh got Direction both of
them have Direction they have these
arrowheads atoms pointing in a given
Direction and that's where you have a
problem because number lines don't have
either one of those two properties they
don't have orthogonality and they don't
have Direction
okay
um those are dimensions that have those
and so we have a problem here because
time is Illustrated as a number line
it's treated as a number line because
they're going to put numbers there right
and they're going to separate them by
seconds minutes hours whatever uh they
you know interval they select
but they're going to call it a dimension
okay you see you see where the problem
is they're going to call this a
dimension is a dimension the same thing
as an underline
and we're going to say no not true okay
so um here it is we have uh two sources
here first the Wikipedia and I like
these contradictions between these two
sources a temporal Dimension or time
Dimension is a dimension of time
I thought it was a number line not a
dimension time is often referred to as
the fourth dimension for this reason but
that is uh not to imply that it is a
spatial dimension
what does uh Stevie Hawking say he says
in relativity there is no real
distinction between the space and time
coordinates you don't even call them
Dimension he calls them coordinates okay
just as there is no real difference
between any two space coordinates I
think that's clear so we have a
contradiction between what the Wikipedia
says and what good old Stevie says okay
one guy says Uh there's no difference
the other guy says oh don't confuse the
time Dimension with the spatial
Dimensions turns out neither one is a
Dimensions they're both number lines and
so the question again is for you to
think is whether a number line is the
same thing as a dimension
um for instance instead of measuring the
position of a well he goes in there and
just explains that there's no difference
between these two you can look that up
later on
from his book famous book
A Brief History of Time
okay so uh here we have a problem with
all these folks because you were saying
hey you know is a is if if time is
Illustrated as a number line keep it as
a number line don't tell me it's a
dimension and again one of the problems
these people have is they say that the
universe is four dimensional
if it's four dimensional uh it means
it's got length width height and who
knows what else no they're saying it's
for number lined
they have four number lines to locate
any point Within
space time that's what they mean it's
the other way around but they say space
time is four dimensional because you
need four coordinates to locate a point
within space time that's the notion the
definition or whatever okay so here we
have the difference between number line
dimension for all those who care to take
note number nine belongs exclusively to
math it doesn't belong to physics at all
we don't use number lines in physics why
because in physics we have to explain
causes and mechanisms
um math is just a language you know and
it's a language that
um uses numbers
and the number line a series of numbers
it has no Direction
as soon as they put that Arrowhead
they're cheating because numbers have no
Direction
what they're trying to show you is that
numbers increase that that's what
they're Counting
remember uh what is a number of numbers
integers that you count and they count
them in a you know you can put them in
any direction you want you can count I
mean the two doesn't follow physically
in a given direction from one the three
doesn't follow in a given direction from
two they just say look we put them in a
certain order so you know that numbers
are increasing in that direction but
there is no direction to Counting
and so the first problem is that there
is no direction for number lines the
second problem it's not orthogonal to
anything and here they put the time
especially when in the space-time
diagrams they put time perpendicular to
so-called space where they put all three
dimensions into one and they call that
space whatever that means you know
physically so they have the space
number line the time number line and
they put these perpendicular to each
other
in what direction does
time run forward backward to the sides
and does it run perpendicular to
anything absolutely not so number line
known as time runs in no direction and
is perpendicular to nothing and that
applies to all number lines okay
number nine it's counting numbers
counting so number line has many
accounts because you're talking about
many numbers it's a dynamic concept okay
there's no static
part of it dimension on the other hand
it's uh has Direction okay has
perpendicularity as you can see there
height is perpendicular to width by
definition which is perpendicular to
length by definition all three of them
are mutually perpendicular time does not
fit in there because we cannot put time
perpendicular to any dimension
okay anyone who does that is dealing
with Dementia not with Dimensions has
perpendicularity or thyronalities uh
perpendicular comes from perpendicular
you do not need to know anything about
angles for that okay here's perpend well
sorry this is the number line bills
gady's number line you can see I was
right we have no Direction there no
perpendicularity okay but uh here let me
show you that what perpendicular means
it comes from this it's uh from
perpendicular and it was a plumb bob
which they used to usually for walls
they would look at the Horizon and say
okay the wall is more or less straight
you know so you don't need to know
um really anything about angles to know
to understand the concept of
perpendicular okay so that's all I'm
trying to show here okay let me get rid
of this one
um it's a qualitative concept you don't
need to know anything about numbers and
no need to know about angles again
numbers okay qualitative angles yeah you
could say uh this one is uh
you know perpendicular and anything
between is half perpendicular whatever
you know you don't you don't really need
to know numbers for to conceptualize an
angle okay now if you want to tell
someone look it's a 30 degree angle yeah
then you're going to have to put a
number in there okay
but then uh we don't need numbers to
understand angles it's just a
qualitative you know two sticks that's
all it is okay uh without knowing the
language of someone else here I'll take
two pencils and do it you're going to
say look this is what this is more or
less what the angle was that I saw
of whatever and you don't even need to
know much of the language or what the
angle exactly was you say it was more or
less like that I think I understand okay
I know what you're talking about neither
one needs to know what how many degrees
that thing was
turned over which is what degrees are
it's how much you uh scan one stick with
respect to another
no magnitudes involved and uh it's a
static concept this Dimension is a
static concept so yeah these two are
very different one is dynamic one is
static the other one has Direction the
other one doesn't and one has magnitude
and the other one doesn't one has
perpendicularity and the other one does
not
okay so here uh we have Google Hawking
and he says that's why he ends up saying
the nonsense that he says in his book he
says it is often helpful to think of the
four what coordinates oh coordinates I
thought it was a dimension okay or a
number nine or whatever of an event a
specifying its position in a four
dimensional space called space-time
it is impossible to imagine a
four-dimensional space yeah no kidding
uh but yeah so he's saying that it's uh
four dimensional no or four coordinates
it's neither one it's four number lined
that's what they're talking about
they're now talking about Dimensions or
coordinates what the problem is that
they Define a dimension as the number of
coordinates and what is a coordinate a
number so it's the number of numbers
they're talking about number lines
they're not talking about dimensions and
so to say that the universe or space
time or whatever it is four dimensional
it's a lie
okay it's alive from every point of view
from the definitional point of view and
from a physics point of view no such
thing as four-dimensionality no such
thing as a universe that is four
dimensional okay in fact the universe is
not even three-dimensional because when
they use the word Universe they're
talking about space and space has no
Dimensions whatsoever
space is Zero Dimensional because it's
nothing
only things have dimensions and space is
the opposite of thing it's a not thing
okay and so uh here we have it it's a
static uh concept for
um
I'm sorry it's a dynamic concept for
number line also okay number and number
line both are Dynamic Dynamic Concepts
okay neither one is a static concept
okay so in the Universal movie you need
at least two frames of the movie two
conceptualize a number line
okay let's get on with some of the
questions uh people had comments here's
uh first one Paul says it says what is
sound have you ever given lectures on
sound uh I don't I've covered it uh you
know not specifically but sound is is
what sound is is compression rare
faction of uh here on Earth right of um
air atoms of air molecules of air
um they just vibrate back and forth and
that's why you can hear because we we've
through Evolution we've adjusted our
ears to accept those vibrations and
understand uh different tonalities
different
um
vibrations of these atoms and molecules
that are banging against our eardrums so
it's no mystery I mean we don't have a
problem with that here at least in
rational science no difference
whatsoever with the establishment on
that okay here we have another phone
says physical connections to
physical physical connections
add them to all other atoms is
physically impossible
uh well we have observed of the universe
so far amounts to an accurate estimate
of 10 to the 82nd power of atoms lots of
atoms that's only in the observable
universe okay well we can see if the
universe is it or what we can calculate
remember these calculations are you know
very ballpark if the universe is
infinite okay now listen to this it
would just uh completely saturate out
with physical connections well if it's
infinite it wouldn't saturate anything
but he doesn't understand that he
contradicts himself I mean if it's
infinite meaning it never ends right
then there is no problem with space okay
and you have all the space you want
at the size of the known universe of the
observed Universe right 10 to the 67 000
power physical connections would be
required right
okay so he calculated with his
calculator I'm sure he didn't count all
that like the other guy said right okay
that would be analogous to tie trying I
guess to put a billion fish in a tank
with a capacity for five fish not enough
space well again if uh if your space is
infinite you have no problem with space
it's not a done deal you know no problem
there the other problem is he he's
talking about fish which is like atoms
not about the connections between fish
which is the connection between atoms
which is what he was challenging so he
doesn't even understand that one
so he made so many years that you know
just in one paragraph or whatever the
three sentences four sentences uh that's
well what can we say no
um we don't have no problems uh
hopefully there are gazillions of atoms
in the universe okay uh every Star has
gazillions of atoms in their gazelle
millions of stars so forget about
counting that
there are countless atoms will never
count them and all we're saying is
between any atom that exists there's
there's a rope that interconnects them
they're physically connected there's an
interconnection physical interconnection
we're done you know so if there are so
many atoms there are so many ropes and
so we can tolerate uh for many atoms
there should be no problem tolerating it
for ropes no so his argument is totally
worthless
okay here we have another fine he says
the following he says Einstein said
velocity of light multiplies Mass
and yeah and he says you can't tell that
to a normal thinking person even funnier
is no one has found that hilarious in
over a hundred years uh absolutely you
know so uh yeah to say that uh velocity
multiplies uh Mass what does that mean
okay
unless you find physical meaning to that
equation it's a calculation right if you
can find physical meaning then you're
doing physics but just to say that
velocity of light multiplies Mass
so we have what seconds squared
uh I'm sorry uh meters per second
squared
um
uh times kilograms
what does that mean
so he's right you know it makes no sense
and people should be laughing at that
with that I'll see you next week